ومعنا من ابل السقي جنوب لبنان مراسل
الجزيره جوني تانيوس كما تنضم الينا من
الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره جفارا
البديري ابدا معك جوني واخر التطورات على
الجبهه ولنبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل عن حزب
الله باستشهاد احد مقاتليه في غاره
اسرائيليه على بلده كفر
شوبه مما لا شك فيه سهام ان حال التوتر
والتصعيد هنا في هذ المناطق الحدوديه
الجنوبيه مستمره فجر هذا اليوم شنت مسيره
اسرائيليه غاره على احد المنازل في بلده
كفرشوبا هنا في القطاع الشرقي ما ادى الى
استشهاد هذا العنصر من حزب الله واصابه
شخص اخر بجروح بالاضافه الى اضرار كبيره
في هذا المنزل الذي تم استهدافه وبعدها
بساعات ايضا شنت المقاتلات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه سلسله من الغارات على منطقه
اللبونه في القطاع الغربي
ودائما ما تتعرض هذه المنطقه في القطاع
الغربي للغارات الاسرائيليه ودائما ما
يقول الجانب الاسرائيلي انه يستهدفوا
مراكز ومقرات تابعه لحزب الله حتى هذه
اللحظه حزب الله لم يعلن عن اي عمليه
نفذها خلال ساعات هذا اليوم يوم امس كان
نفذ ثماني عمليات الابرز من بينها طبعا
استهداف مقر القياده الشماليه بمسارات
انقضاض قال حزب الله يوم امس ان هذه
العمليه جاءت ردا على لا اختيال القائد
الميداني البارس في وحده الرضوان وسام
طويل في بلدته خربه سلم وايضا في سياق
الردود على اختيال نائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي في حركه حماس الاسبوع الماضي في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت صالح العاروري
طبعا حزب الله مستمر على نهجه لناحيه
تكثيف العمليات العسكريه باتجاه المواقع
العسكريه الاسرائيليه تجمعات الجنود
الاسرائيليين دائما ما يقول حزب الله انه
ينفذ هذه العمليات في في اطار المسانده
والدعم لقطاع غزه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
ايضا في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه لم تتوقف ا
كان من خلال الغارات التي شنت على بلدتي
كفر كلا وال العديسه او الغارات ايضا التي
شنت يوم امس من خلال المسيرات على منطقه
الغندور وعلى منطقه خربه سلم
والغاره التي حصلت على احدى السيارات في
منطقه خربه سلم جاءت على هامش تشييع
القائد الميداني في حزب الله وسام طويل
على المستوى السياسي ايضا هناك مجموعه من
النقاط التي يمكن التوقف عندها الزياره
التي تقوم بها وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
وطبعا الملف الاساسي الذي ستبحث مع
المسؤولين اللبنانيين هو الاوضاع هنا في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه وما يمكن ان نسميه
الجهود الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه المبذوله من
اجل تخفيف التوتر ومنع انفجار الامور في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه يضاف الى ذلك ايضا
زياره مهمه سيقوم بها يوم امس كبير يوم غد
عفوا عفوان كبير مستشاري الرئيس الامريكي
اموس هوكست الذي كان توسط في ملف الحدود
البحريه هو يصل الى بيروت يوم غد يلتقي
عدد من المسؤولين اللبنانيين وكانت له
ايضا زيارات في اوقات سابقه في بيروت
وطبعا الملف الاساسي هو خفض التصعيد في
هذه المنطقه ودائما ما يعبر المسؤولين
الامريكيين عن سعيهم وطلبهم خفض التصعيد
وعدم توجه الامور هنا في هذه المناطق
الحدوديه الجنوبيه الى حرب مفتوحه بين حزب
الله وال الجانب الاسرائيلي وان تبقى
الامور ضمن ضوابط معينه نعم جوني